انا اسمي بشرى عندي 12 سنه واولى اعدادي
انا واطفالي كتير زيي في دماغنا تساؤلات
بندور لها على اجابه زي مثلا ليه في
كائنات بتعيش في البحر وغيرها بيعيش في
البر ليه ما نقدرش نعيش على كوكب غير كوكب
الارض ليه اللبان مطاطي بالشكل ده ليه
الماء سر الحياه وغيرها كتير من الاسئله
اللي بتيجي في دماغنا ولقيت مبادره بتشجع
الاطفال انهم يوصلوا للاجابات اللي هم
عاوزينها لنفسهم
في الاول بنكتب اسئله كتير وبنختار منهم
اكتر سؤال احنا مهتمين به او عندنا فضول
ناحيته بعدها بناخد السؤال بتاعنا رحله
بحث عبر الانترنت والكتب والخبراء في
الموضوع بتاعهم وبعدها
بعد ما نلاقي الاجابه اللي احنا عايزينها
بنلف قصه تقدر توصل المعلومه اللي احنا
وصلنا لها للاطفال بطريقه سهله وبسيطه
عشان نقدر نفيد بعض بالقصص بتاعتنا
وبعد ما نكتب القصص
بيختاروا كذا قصه من القصص الكتير
وبينشروها في تطبيق قراءه للاطفال وشويه
منهم بينشروها في معرض الكتاب عشان يشجعوا
الاطفال ان هم يكتبوا قصص مفيده وانا كان
عندي تساؤل عن السلاحف المائيه والسلاحف
البريه وليه ما نقدرش ليه ما تقدرش
السلحفاه البريه تنزل الميه طب ايه اللي
هيحصل لو نزلت الميه
وكتبت قصه عنها وسميتها الاستاذ زحلوف
واتمشت قصتي معرض الكتاب سنه 2022
وفي الموسم اللي بعده كان عندي تساؤل عن
اللبان ليه مطاطي وهو ايه مكوناته وازاي
بيتصنع وبعد رحله بحث عرفت كل المعلومات
اللي عايزه اعرفها عن اللبان
وكتبت قصه عنها وسميتها رحله علكه واتنشت
قصتي في تطبيق ابجد
الرحله كانت ممتعه ومفيده جدا وبالنسبه لي
دي حاجه مفيده انك تدور على اجابات
لاسئلتك بنفسك
وبقول لكل الاطفال يدوروا على اجابات
لاسئلتهم بنفسهم بالبحث في الكتب في
الانترنت في المصادر الموثوق منها او
يستعينه بخبير
في العلم كن فضوليا واكثر السؤال كن
فضوليا واطلق الخيال
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]